hey guys I have been a little m.i.a
because I've been here in Cuba no not
for work on a vacation an educational
vacation I planned it before Obama said
it was cool but even though it's
difficult to bring a camera crew in here
because they're very wary about
journalists it's amazing how many
stories there are to tell just in Havana
alone in every corner in every home you
see every person you talk to there is a
world from the colonial history of Cuba
which is incredibly brutal to the
inequality of the Batista regime to the
incredible feat that was the communist
revolution - now when things are
changing slowly
he was a country that's stuck in time in
a lot of ways thanks to the US economic
embargo but also it feels like a
parallel world where problems the rest
of the world has Cuba has the complete
opposite health care for example is free
but doctors have a hard time making ends
meet crazy what surprised me was that
people are pretty open about their
critiques of the government they're
thankful for what the Revolution and the
Castro regime has brought them and yet
they're really now ready for change for
example Wi-Fi would be nice
whatever happens politically between the
u.s. and Cuba one thing is for sure the
Cuban people are incredibly resilient
and well-educated and great dancers
dundun a Cuban slang for the fluttering
sound a hummingbird makes and the name
of a Cuban Twitter like social media
platform that was exposed earlier this
year as being a project sponsored by
none other than the United States of
America